I think that for Iran to have survived
and made a life for herself she almost
needed that edgy personality otherwise
she would have been you know destroyed
brand was not treated very well back in
the late 50s early 60s first of all she
was not an academic second she was a
capitalist which annoyed people on the
left and she was an atheist which
annoyed people on the right so she was a
loner she was also her harshness in her
insistence that she had to beat the
table every time she spoke didn't even
endear her to people who might have
listened a little bit more carefully had
she been a little bit more pleasant but
her unpleasantness I think ultimately
can be fully justified given the
treatment she was given when she came
out of the Soviet Union told the truth
about that country and nobody paid
attention to her and she was terribly
upset she had been a fan of America
through its symbols through its art
through to movies to its atmospherics
and then she finally ends up in the
middle of the country and brings warning
about this disastrous experiment and
people dismiss her well she was just
terribly upset and you know different
personalities react differently to being
upset like that and rants reaction was
to become quite bellicose you know but
that doesn't take very much away from
the substance of her thought it just
makes her a difficult sell apple shrug
was a catharsis because there were some
scenes in it they were absolutely
gripping when I read it I was in the Air
Force I stayed up two nights sleepless
foodless and just read through it
I did cut out called speech and made a
little book out of it which I would then
later study you know but the train ride
for example was riveting the the power
of that writing describing that train
ride with Dagny on the train just sent
me the money talk was fabulous the sex
talk was okay a little bit a bit
old-fashioned let me put it this way and
quite believable that I found drain and
sex completely incompatible anyway so
Atlas Shrugged just had wonderful
caricatures of really hateful people you
knew in your life at least mine having
lived under the rule of a Nazi father
and under the rule of Communists
government I mean these people were
really like that that this is not a
caricature this was the the depiction of
these people their mentality their the
way of not really paying attention to
another person's humanity this is a sort
of characteristic of all of these
entrenched bureaucrats and Atlas
demonstrates this very well that these
bad guys are bad because they violate
humanity not because they violate God
not because they violate some ideal out
of this world but because they're not
well grounded in in in the way of human
life John Galt represents the human
capacity and willingness to take one's
life and make the most of it I think
rands great legacy is to have
rescued this tradition from obscurity
and given it a passionate twist and
captured it in fiction which excited a
lot more people than some dry treatise
would have then of course to give
capitalism this sort of backing where it
is completely pro life pro human beings
pro human life and that to show that
without freedom one is usually much
worse off than with it there can be some
rare bizarre exceptions but if you want
to know the general truth of it the free
society is the superior alternative to
anything else that has been thought up
by human beings on the political front
you